[Musique]
suit paysanne en agriculture biologique
et je fais de la culture de fruits bio
et je transforme une partie le reste je
vends en frais je me suis trouvé en
difficulté suite à l'achat d'une d'une
machine qui m'a posé un certain nombre
de problèmes et j'avais déjà beaucoup de
fatigue physique pour moi c'était
j'avais du mal à trouver une issue à ce
problème et je connaissais solidarité
paysans parce que il m'avait déjà
soutenu à l'époque où je me suis
retrouvé en épuisement physique en 2017
et oui nous ont aidés à passer ce cap un
peu difficile
[Musique]
l'agriculteur doit tout faire que ce
soit ces céréales ou c mais en plus il
doit gérer tout ce qui est paperasserie
et qu'il doit gérer
oui tout en fait là la globalité on va
dire de son travail alors qu'un salarié
il fait son boulot quand il a fini ses
huit heures et rentrer chez lui là ça
paye au bout du mois tandis que
l'agriculteur c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué la globalité du travail doit
être fait il ya des fois quelquefois il
n'est pas sûr d'avoir ma paye à la fin
du mois
ouais je pense qu'il faut vraiment oser
prendre le téléphone et pied appelé
appelé l'association en dix ans la voilà
je n'y arrive pas si besoin d'un petit
coup de pouce et voir plus qu'un petit
coup de pouce mais parce que moi je
considère que le problème que j'ai eu il
est minime par rapport à d'autres
collègues qui sont dans des situations
je trouve dramatique et qui peuvent que
ce serait bien dommage qui se passe des
choses terribles
il ya déjà beaucoup de suicides dans le
milieu à l'école c'est une activité que
qui est épuisante qui demande beaucoup
physiquement mais beaucoup s'y
d'investissement moral
[Musique]